ce lundi matin pas question d'arriver en
retard au lycée les bacheliers débutai
leur premier jour d'épreuve avec la
philosophie des 7h et demi les 300
élèves du lycée de Villarois gui en cour
attendaient l'ouverture des portes à
quelques minutes de l'examen certains
rigolent avec les copains pour oublier
la pression et d'autres révisent jusqu'à
la dernière minute alors stressés ces
étudiants bah stressé comme tout le
monde en fait bien pas trop stressé ma
coefficient 7 c'est matière la plus
importante il faut pas que je le loupe
allez les portes s'ouvrent un coup d'œil
au tableau et on fil s'installer dans sa
salle stylo sur la table bouteille d'eau
et de quoi combler une petite faim mais
attention rien d'autre cette année la
lutte antifraude a été renforcée
sanction est comprise personne n gardé
son téléphone portable sur aucun aucun
moyen de communication avec l'extérieur
les copies bien scellées sont
distribuées et c'est parti pour 4 heures
d'épreuve parmi les sujets sur lesquels
ils vont plancher que devons-nous à
l'état ou encore le travail permet- de
prendre conscience de soi dans les
coulisses une dizaine de personnes
travaillent pour que tout se déroule au
mieux les professeurs quant à eux
participe à la surveillance des épreuves
l'organisation technique cette année
nous a permis de je dirais d'organiser
en fonction des étag le bac général sur
un niveau et le bac technologique sur un
deuxième niveau ce qui évite
effectivement de faire trop
d'aller-venue dans dans l'établissement
mais c'est vrai que la mise en place du
baccalauréat nécessite quand même de
faire quand même quelques kilomètres
surtout sur une semaine
bien loin de l'aspect organisationnel
les élèves sortent peu à peu des salles
d'examen parfois même avant la fin de
l'épreuve au bout de 3h d'épreuve au
lieu de 4 mais ça s'est très bien passé
bah pas terrible terrible j'espère
attendre le 8 si possible au moins 12
j'espère pour le savoir il faudra
attendre le 5 juillet d'ici là les
épreuves continuent demain le lycée
accueillera les élèves de Première pour
leurs épreuves anticipées